is this is all getting too political and
I can't be saying these things on camera
this is my manager like right I don't I
can't get Council for none of this
please this can't go on YouTube I'm
sorry I can't I can't do this honestly
you didn't tell me what it was about I
can't I'm sorry no I don't sign the
disclosure so you can't put this on
YouTube so if this goes on YouTube yeah
no you can't put this you don't have
anything you can't you're not legally if
you do a public interview you can't I'm
gonna be honest this guy I think was too
drunk to be doing this interview I don't
even know if he knew what I was asking
he may regret doing this interview now
but you know